there's a couple ways I wanted to go I
want to go to I wanted to talk about
orgasmic meditation because I got into
that for a while I wanted to talk about
some other things but we're gonna have
to do at a different time because know
how to do om I was in there you got in
and I was in yeah I was in for like six
months oh dude I was I got bit by a
[ __ ] uh Bichon up in Topanga Canyon
touching some lady yeah and it was all
sanctioned this was sanctioned you know
by the Commission or whatever it was
legal have you talked about this yeah I
don't know if we talked about it people
keep asking you elaborate I think it
might be more interesting than some of
our questions please elaborate Theo my
boyfriend my ex-boyfriend was trained to
do under them yeah and he did it to some
strange woman okay I'll tell you what
happens a lot I know it's not hot it's
supposed to be very like mechanical so I
you know pee-wee's big adventure right
you remember that yeah the film right so
they have this lovely lady was an
actress in at name eg daily and she
played Pee Wee's girlfriend can you
bring her up demon
she played Pee Wee's girlfriend in the
original movie and she also was the
voice of Tommy pickles oh my god and get
it on here yeah okay Wow there we go
so eg came on my podcast allegedly which
was my original podcast with Matt Weiss
and she was awesome she was extremely
charming and we kind of really related
she's super super cool and we related
and she invited me to this thing called
orgasm annotation the second she spoke
about it I felt just into it you just
click on just any of them movies how
many pickles one so the second she you
know I felt into it so next you know she
invites me to this place downtown and
we're in this it's like a seminar they
got coffee and you know a little bit you
know some pineapple cut some cuts of
pineapple and cuts of different fruits
you know at the front people's milling
around and doing that next thing you
know they got a lady up and they closed
the doors about 250 people in there they
have a lady at the front they got her
spread-eagle you know what I'm saying
which is uh which I think should be our
national bird you know what I'm saying
boy I salute that dude about any
brothers would kneel if they [ __ ] let
that thing fly across the stadium I know
that I hope you write that down that's
really funny well I mean that's just
what's going on you know so anyhow next
thing
no you know they're teaching how to
diddle diddle the lady at the front of
the room right yes and there's a doctor
up there yeah so fast-forward five hours
and a lunch break they've got us paired
off partnered off in a different
twosomes
and you're just diddling whoever you're
set up with and you're fooling mean this
you have gloves on there's doctors
walkin around like it's like lost it's
like one of the you know which should
have been maybe the last episode of lost
that they never put together because
dudes are [ __ ] losers who couldn't
you know who just wrote their way in a
cell in advertising but but anyhow like
they got da and you're touching a lady
and people are spraying out across the
room like you can tell who's doing good
and who's doing bad can we talk about
like it's all in her wounds but like why
okay women enjoy it why do the men enjoy
it what is that relation so here's the
thing they teach you how to pleasure a
woman with your hand right the woman
gets pleasured and this goes back to
what you're talking about earlier it
feels like they don't have to give any
reciprocation because there's no
reciprocation for the man but here's
what the man gets oh you you there's
it's a 15-minute process and it's a safe
process where a woman knows she can feel
sexual pleasure from a actual man and
that they don't have to give anything in
return so it's a complete safe space to
feel good and also there are terms that
the woman can give to the to her male
instructor that lets the man know how
they can better please the woman right
and there's specific terms that don't
make the man feel bad if he's not doing
it right
right so it's it's very calculated and
as a man here's what you get you
actually get to make a woman feel good
with a woman's permission and with a
woman's direction in a comfortable way
where you're not just guessing and
assuming and going off of things you
heard in grade school or things that
some [ __ ] you know you know idiot or
some you know older brothers friend who
now works at a [ __ ] Chevron or
something for 40 years told you and so
you actually get to make a woman feel
good and so you leave out of there bro
when you leave out of there dude you
feel like damn just you know John Wayne
Gacy or whatever who's the UM John Wayne
Gacy is a serial killer but you feel
like you know like you have like you
know in your in your fingertips you have
the magic yeah but
you got a woman off you didn't get
anything you didn't get anything you
didn't bust you got all this chi built
up so you're rolling around town just
with the magic touch you know you got
that King Midas you know you got that
clitoral King Midas you're running
around and what are the words can you
reveal what are some of the things that
women can say to direct you in different
ways yeah higher lower more pressure
less pressure can you go a little faster
please can you go a little slower please
to the right you know to the left now
slot you know and that was a joke I did
use one time in the thing and he got a
couple of people to laugh and one late
even farted a couple people over when I
did use that joke but so anyway so next
thing you know I'm on the floor I'm in
on the floor of a huge warehouse in
downtown Los Angeles there's about 80
people that are coupled off into groups
of 40 some people don't even get
partners they got [ __ ] set off the
Highland party dude but then but next
thing you know you get to the enemy like
wow this lady came or didn't come but
still felt good what is what do you do
after she comes like do you shake hands
do you look at each other I thing you
have to like slow down it's like kind of
like a downward stroke that you would
use on the woman it was like a downward
pressure and then in the end you use
like this kind of closing press you
really put both your hands on her vagina
with like this and you like kind of
press on it for like two or three
seconds there's this whole template of
how it all goes down and I remember one
guy they had in a wheelchair he got
partnered up with a lady so this dude I
think was like his let you know in his
legs hidden me feeling his legs he got
hit by a [ __ ] car bus or something or
thrown off a horse or something but um
we had to pick him up out of wheelchair
and a horse and then got hit by a bus it
could've ended that [ __ ] HB combo
[Laughter]
nothing after that oh it's nothing after
that but the wild part was I remember
lifting him up out of the wheelchair and
laying him next to his partner so he
could still use his arm so he got it you
know he did his job
and I remember we put him back in the
wheelchair he felt lighter oh she could
feel like he just felt he got some mojo
back yeah cuz it's got to be taken from
you when you're in a wheelchair and and
and feel maybe maybe that was like his
way
yeah I mean I think if heat is done for
more ladies he too [ __ ] waltzed out
of it that's you know but it's just
crazy the empowerment that you get by
not by making somebody else feel good
and so then next thing you know you're
in the group you meet up once or twice a
week there's like these crazy meetups
and you're diddling whoever shows up
you're partnering up there's almost a
square dance thing in the beginning
where it's like which is it okay if we
um they call it oming orgasmic
meditation is it okay if we um together
and next seem like yes so you partner up
and you know you set each other off and
you're diddling 50 60 70 year old women
you know you literally like you these
are women that you're not like attracted
to oh no I was best looking man and
woman in the whole [ __ ] place a lot
of times but then you're on the easy
road then you're they have an app you're
on and now you're [ __ ] driving around
telling you but business meeting and a
half hour later in here in some
apartment urine I was in a nice house in
the hills a couple times what is the
process before and after when you're
meeting with these women what's the
conversation leaving at before and after
so everybody's on the tight time scale
or living their regular lives but they
want to have this moment it's all
meditation it really I literally
definitely need to do this because I
need to have orgasms that are brought on
by someone else but I don't want all the
follow-up of like Willy call me or like
do I like him or do I work then it
sounds like it's only human you need an
escort no why not this what's what you
could do this so this is what happens I
would show up we would have we'd have
text in advance communicate in advance
okay I'll be there 12:15 you know I'm
five minutes late no worries so we get
there and the person the woman has a
nest set up and a nest is just a way you
set up pillows and a towel so that they
can lay down so the woman can lay down
the man you roll in you got your bat you
got your little gloves you got your you
know and straight up dude I've always
wanted to be at my heart I believe a
cafeteria worker right deep inside of me
there's a [ __ ] beautiful big lady
[ __ ] scoop and cobbler you know into
the plate of a young boy who's hurting
in a lot of different ways but for a
moment feel some warmth when he sees
this woman you know and there's also
like unnecessary hair nets everywhere
you know and I [ __ ] love that and so
so anyway you know you show up you have
your gloves you have your little thing
of
boob and you know you show up and the
woman takes her pants off and you're
sitting you kind of sit cross-legged to
the lady lays down you put a leg over
her body here facing just everything you
don't even looking at it like she
doesn't you don't make eye contact it's
none of that [ __ ] you know this ain't ya
this ain't a family you know I love the
leg over cuz it like holds you down it's
a little bit of its secure you get onto
the UH it's like whenever you get onto
the Batman ride at [ __ ] Six Flags and
like where's the and you're like yeah
it's just a simple bar but you're like
no I feel I'm not gonna fall out yeah
I'm not gonna fall out did I make sure I
put my camera in the cubbyhole for I got
on yes I did everything's secure right
so then you know you have the woman's
underpants off you have the vagina
you're kind of looking down at it and
then you just have this kind of stroke
that you start to do you know right they
teach you this method yeah and they
teach you this method and the woman
knows what's going on you've learned the
method in the classroom so now it's a
real practical thing and then it seems
to be a thing that functions constantly
and that people do
nobody's raping each other there's not a
lot of that it's like a meditation that
is um apparently is respected by a lot
of people and they they used to charge
like to be in like the group there was
like a fee to learn it now I don't even
think they charge wow I think it's just
a you know just a thing that's going on
now what happened to me was I got
[ __ ] attacked by a bichon I was
touching this lady up in um Topanga
Canyon so that's where I always think
about getting a lawyer and stuff and
finally I'm like man [ __ ] it man that
like bit oh yeah this thing [ __ ] bit
me dawg and I respect it you know and I
told her to lock the dog up that was a
thing and I've been over there a couple
times and it's hard to also fend a dog
off while you're trying to touch a
woman's crotch you know what I'm saying
but look I've had experience of that
going full circle trying to [ __ ] while
pee or throw rocks at all kind of coming
back it's all a little bit nicer do you
still do this I don't do it I would get
back into it what made you get away from
it the Bashan attack yeah yeah
definitely the attack and I've shared a
room with the Bashan I've shared a room
with a child too when I was in college
not an Asian person an actual [ __ ]
animal and and so I've been around you
know some some dogs I've been attacked
by dogs I got attacked by dogs and cats
one time on a birthday well you know
I've had different experiences with
hanage you've seen a lot of vaginas
we're doing this like how many girls do
you think you've owned with maybe 30
okay what um what have you learned about
vaginas like cuz that's a different
that's a different thing than a hookup
cuz in a hookup a lot of times you don't
get to like really look and see like
what the mechanics are have you learned
about vaginas in a way that maybe I
don't even understand cuz I only know
mine yeah like what what ur what are you
seeing out there I'm floating like what
do you don't like what is what are some
recommendations if you were if you would
if you were about to go service a woman
what would you want her to do down there
check it out make sure that thing's
running top oil you know nothing wild
down there I don't want some you know
you should have got it serviced a couple
times you've been skipping out because
you you know just make sure that your
vagina is like kind of you know you
wanna have a clean vagina clean yeah cuz
there's a lot I would say one out of
seven vaginas is not clean how could
they not clean up if they know you're
coming over clean you're just also I
used to know a girl and this is she
would put a finger in a vagina and then
taste it herself to make sure that it
tasted okay yeah yeah yeah
which seems very wild to me you know
what I'm saying I mean I [ __ ] I've
slipped over to the buffet and had
something off of it before I paid for it
sure but but I respected it I respected
it it's like ya know what's going on
it's the same thing like as a guy like
you'll do this and I'll be their [ __ ]
and rub your hands you know I'll
probably lick myself off your face so
I'm not opposed like that like tasting
myself I think it's actually kind of hot
so like you might as well be like okay
what am I having a good day right like
what's going on yeah you don't need your
[ __ ] toe some mints in there yes
sometimes you just need to like do
something else but [ __ ] yeah
I can't believe those don't exist but
gents I one time I had enough ladies the
gents I knew and I should definitely
sell this I put a gummy worm up my
vagina once because my or was that good
that game there used to be a game people
were doing online I'm really hiding gum
or was their vagina no way yeah it was
like or know somebody reenacted like
Lord of the Flies where they had like a
cave and it look like you the gummy
worms were coming up that's funny no I
did this because I was picking up my
ex-boyfriend at
boyfriend at the time I think Mordor to
tell him it was his favorite food was
these like gummy worms and I would
always buy them for him and I was
thinking about the airport and I knew
that he would finger me immediately when
we got in the car cuz it's my favorite
thing and getting driving while you're
being fingered is like so exciting so I
put one in Jersey right before I picked
him up so he gets in the car and he's
fingering me and he's like what the [ __ ]
is and he pulled out a gummy worm and it
was just like a funny joke that's
awesome yeah I was I was pretty good um
no definitely and that and that
so in Virginia just sold a thousand
magic kits of a gent know it seems good
but here's what I'm saying is that uh uh
we talking about um you need to get back
into oh yeah like you just got it yeah
it's just the scent that was the biggest
thing and I thought of that that was it
I mean there's this you know I noticed
this as well like it gave me a different
respect for women because if you're like
pleasure and a woman who's 65 years old
you know it's like you start to realize
oh that like you know older women do you
know they are still women they are they
do need pleasure and they do you should
treat them like a woman like that's what
it may mean it made me realize a little
bit more like oh you know this is a
woman this is a different thing they may
not want to [ __ ] her but she's still a
woman that has sexual desires and
deserves yes and deserves like some sort
of treatment or some it just puts things
in a different it puts things in a
different frame than our society puts
things in